[Music]
it's that time again Sony have
officially revealed the game's PS plus
essential subscribers can download in
January 2023. Tuesday the 3rd of January
to be precise let's do this first up on
both PS4 and PS5 is the sublime Jedi
Fallen order set after Order 66 is in
full effect we play as Carl kestis in a
story officially recognized as part of
the Star Wars ongoing saga it's a Canon
story The Core gameplay is made up of
two elements the exploration and puzzle
solving seen in games like Tomb Raider
and the combat mechanics of something
like Dark Souls timing your sword swings
blocking correctly and looking for enemy
weaknesses are important especially on
the harder difficulties but it's way
more forgiving than a typical Soul spawn
game the best bits are the force
abilities and the surprisingly
interesting story pushing enemies away
or deflecting laser fire feels as epic
as you'd expect and after about 20 hours
of gameplay you'll reach the finale
which lives up to expectations too
another great inclusion in Fallen order
is metroidvania style backtracking going
back to a location you haven't been to
in hours with a brand new ability which
reveals a completely new path to explore
it's such a good game it's already
getting
it's on the way professional reviewers
love Fallen order with the average score
about 8.5 out of 10. so it's good you
should play it and I'll race you to the
platinum trophy next on PS4 is Fallout
76 I shall be honest on release Fallout
76 was a dumpster fire of bugs and
emptiness the iconic open world RPG
attempted to replace NPCs with the real
life players which resulted in a world
lacking engaging missions and stories
over four years have passed since then
and hundreds of bug fixes and narrative
updates have attempted to reshape the
player experience and those updates
include reintroducing NPCs all
throughout the world representing
different factions Moroccan to Fallout 3
and 4. the story is set as nuclear bombs
and civilization as we know it and 25
years later it's time to exit the vaults
that saved us and Venture back into the
world Fallout 76 is rated 2.8 out of 10
by players on Metacritic and a huge 5
out of 10 by the pro quit critics yikes
I wonder how many of those reviewers
went back to see Fallout 76 had improved
and finally a game with an old school
Vibe Axiom Verge 2. it's a metroidvania
outing which deliberately looks like the
8-Bit versions of the games it's
inspired by the story sends a mother to
Antarctica looking for her daughter she
stumbles upon the ability to harness
Nano machines that give her new powers
and off she goes essentially this is a
2d side scroller but there is a really
clever dual reality mechanic in Axiom
Verge 2 as we can shift to a hidden
Dimension the story combines the Earthly
Overworld with this artificial
underworld to build a pretty interesting
story but the thing is if you want to
see the final cut scene you'll have to
finish the game with a high percentage
or you could just look on YouTube I
guess so that's it that's the month and
that's our games what are you playing in
2023 Jedi Fallen order right I'm Adam
it's been a pleasure all the best for
2023 I'll see you next time
[Music]
foreign
[Music]